I
Steve thank you so much for joining us
on the front runners my pleasure you are
a man very much in demand oh yes yes I
am you'll see an orange chair that's for
you okay Steve it's really great to see
you here today Thanks perhaps my
favorite review of your performance in
foxcatcher came from your wife on 60
minutes where she said she instantly
forgot she was watching her own husband
you must be really relishing all the
great response to this film and this
performance yeah the way it's being
received is I think it's it's gratifying
I think it's especially gratifying for
me to watch Bennett soaking it up
because he's lived with this for eight
years and it's you know it's his it's
really his you're at such a great point
in your career doing fantastic things
with your comedic work and your dramatic
work but is there a moment and
experience a person back in your earlier
days that really helped you figure out
that you could do important things with
your work there was a teacher in second
grade named mr. Blackman and I'll never
forget it we were doing the first
Thanksgiving between the Native
Americans and pilgrims hmm and very
dramatic and it it was my first foray
into the Dramatic Arts and I was a
native american and i was paddling a
canoe and it seemed like such a simple
thing I remember I was paddling the
canoe and then after the scene mr.
Blackman said now wait did you see what
Steve did he paddled on both sides of
the canoe we're just miming but I
paddled and then I changed the paddle
and paddled the other side realism
realism he said if he paddled on one
side the canoe would have gone in a
circle he understood the the dynamics of
the water and the physics of it all and
he paddled on both sides and it seems
like such a simple thing but I'll never
forget it I had someone uh single me out
like like so early on and give me credit
for something that was so simple
something clicked I have to say
something inside said that felt really
good does mr. Blackman know or did he do
if he's no longer with us that this was
such an important moment well that's
interesting you ask because he passed
away about six months ago and his son
got in touch with me after he passed
away and apparently I was part of his
eulogy because he had kept a poem that I
wrote as a little kid in second grade
and he kept it with him like in his
archives and he had no idea that you
know any of this was going to happen he
just like enacted with this poem that I
wrote he was a great educator because he
made kids feel special and and that what
they were doing was important and that
every every child was a value so that
that really stuck with me it just made
me feel good about oh maybe it's
something that that I can do all right I
want to take a look at a really great
scene from foxcatcher we'll watch it
together with these remote controls in
our hands okay and we can pause it and
discuss key moments okay this is a scene
near the beginning of the film where
your character John coupon who's an heir
to the DuPont family fortune meets Mark
Schultz who's an Olympic wrestler for
the first time you've summoned him to
your estate to have a talk with him
right so let's take a look at Foxcatcher
do you have any idea why I should come
here today no no well mark you do you
have any idea who I am now one of the
reasons we chose this scene is because
it really is the first time we're
meeting DuPont for real and hearing him
speak what was important for you to get
across in this early scene I was just
thinking about how Bennett laid out that
introduction because when you first
first see DuPont it's a wide shot you
see him from the side and they're just
shaking hands he's meeting just just
before the same and it's almost like a
horror movie you know you're and and
Bennett equates the movie to a horror
movie from time to time because there is
that element of danger there's a
foreboding there's something hanging
over a politic Eric ters from the very
beginning and it's interesting that you
freeze it right there
on that smile because this scene is
about as at ease and well-adjusted
socially as you'll ever see this guy
well let's keep watching here some rich
guy calls you on the phone I want Mark
Schultz to come visit me i mean what i
love about what we're seeing here is
that this portrayal is a confluence of
this great writing the look of the
character your demeanor just the way
that you're sitting makes you uneasy
what's you and what's not you obviously
there's the teeth that are not yours and
the nose obviously bill Corso designed
the makeup and spent six or seven months
doing camera tests and working with me
coming to my house so there was a line
that we wanted to get up to but not
cross over wanted to look as much like
DuPont because he'd a very specific look
and it was off-putting I think a lot of
who he was um can be attributed to what
he looked like well in is certainly in
part again I think it's it's someone who
doesn't have that filter doesn't doesn't
really have a sense of how other people
view him that's perfectly put there's no
social grace no at all no well let's see
what Channing's reaction is well I'm a
wrestling coach and I have a deep love
the sport of wrestling that I want you
to speak with you about your future
about what you hope to achieve now I
love that Mark Schultz played by
Channing is looking at DuPont like he's
got three heads here right I mean he
doesn't know what to think does he know
I don't think he knows what to think I
think he's he's obviously dubious but at
the same time in the scene you find that
DuPont is saying all of the things that
mark really wants to hear the things
that he cherishes eat DuPont has a way
of tapping into you the the spirit of
patriotism and devotion
to perfection and and all things things
mark hold so dear in in his heart DuPont
is is is speaking his language he's also
suspicious at this point and and not not
quite there it feels that way let's keep
watching what do you hope to achieve
mark I also read that Bennett had you
write something on a piece of paper and
keep in your pocket almost something
that you don't like about yourself to
help you with this characterization is
that true it is specifically it was a
secret about myself that no one knew and
I wrote it down on a piece of paper and
and had it during the scene and it
sounds like sort of an acting trick
something you'd learn and in school you
know an exercise there's something very
vulnerable just sitting in your pocket
and even if you're not thinking about
even if you're not conscious it's there
and it's going to inform what's going on
where's that piece of paper now oh I
have no idea probably probably wardrobe
has it posted on a lot of bulletin board
open does it have your name on it here's
the end want to be the best in the world
want to go to world one go I'm gonna go
to 88 Olympics and soul when gold it's
good
I'm proud of you even that lion is
creepy I'm proud of you they just met
yeah as I was watching that again I
thought about the pauses and I think
that's a part of the equation that
wasn't there the first time I think we
were doing a scene when we first got
together and started running this and by
the time we did this we were very
comfortable within our skins as these
characters and chanting I really didn't
converse a lot when we were doing this
we kind of stayed apart from one another
and then it said that after each take as
he was editing he noticed we'd be
talking and he'd yell cut and we'd
immediately turn away from one another
we didn't want to connect personally and
something we ever talked about it's just
it just sort of happened naturally but i
think the pauses were something that
that happened organically later on as
well well it's such a fascinating seen
in the unease only for shadows what is
to come so I'm glad we were able to talk
about it congratulations and thanks so
much for being here I really appreciate
it be sure to watch foxcatcher so you
can see Steve's phenomenal performance
and thanks so much for watching fandango
frontrunners to say thank you for being
here with us we have made you your own
Fandango gift card so please take your
friends and family to the movies have a
good time if you say so awful so now the
only one thing you have to do is take
your picture with me there's your camera
one two three Thank You effects
you